Ngày 1 năm, một bộ ngoài ra Trung Quốc tuyên bố không thấy đổi thiện chi hợp tác với video dừa là
và sẵn sàng gần kết về các nước Mỹ là tên để cố mứng phó với những biến đồng rất tạm của tình gình của tế
pháp biểu tại khoa báo tuần kì, người phán ngôn bộ ngoài ra Trung Quốc lâm kìm khăn định
mắt kinh kinh định của mộ Mỹ là tinh và kháy bay là khu vực hoa bình
Đồng thời phản đối mọi hình thức khán thiệt tư bến ngoài
vào công việc nội bộ của các khu gia trong khu vực
Tế bộ đường ra Trung Quốc cảnh tổng thống mình đôi nên trong đường ra các pháp biểu kính sáng
Linh quan đến video dừa là và một số nước Mỹ là tình khác
Chúng liên vực hợp tác dầu khi với video dừa là phía Trung Quốc nhấn mạnh
các hợp đồng hợp tác sống phương phương phương ở với lợp pháp khu tế và lợp pháp của hai nước
Hợp tác dầu khi không bị anh hưởng bởi biến động chính trị tại video dừa là
Trung Quốc cũng hỏi thúc quá sĩnh tình nương sử dụng
Cái hợp là mối đây soạn Trung Quốc lâm kai cơ ước
Tế theo đổi lợp xe nhấn mạnh đối thoại là con đường phố hợp để sự li khab biệt